this historic moment of allowing
thousands of lifers out of prison it's a
win-win for the people coming out and
the public hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for
riesen TV we're here with Cady Galloway
and Kevin Bilal Chatman Cady is one of
the filmmakers behind the new
documentary of the return which follows
the journey of several former California
prison inmates as they reenter the world
after serving decades behind bars under
three strike sentencing Bilal is one of
the subjects of the documentary and
served 11 years in state prison after
getting his third strike for selling
drugs to an undercover officer katie
bilal thank you very much for talking to
us thank you so much for having it thank
you and below you've been out for almost
three years now what's the transition
from prison to the outside world been
like for you transition for me has been
pretty tough at times you know we had to
get right into what I was gonna do when
I came back I had to get my license I
had to get my IDs I had to get my social
security card build a resume and then
work from there and Katie three-strikes
went into effect here in California in
1994 could you explain just in basic
terms what is three strikes and then how
did it become so widespread in the
United States so California I believe
was the second three strike state it was
passed in California after a couple of
horrific gruesome incidents involving
children and people who had been
previously incarcerated and were now
free and so there was a legitimate fear
public fear and anger about how could
this happen
the public was sold this idea that we
were going to take care of the worst of
the worst just the most violent
dangerous predators or snatching
children from their beds that sort of
thing in reality the way the law was
written
that and this is the only three strikes
state of now more than 30 in the country
where someone could in fact be sent to
prison for life for a non-violent non
serious offense so they were called
wobblers and prosecutors could decide
whether they wanted to charge them as
misdemeanors or felonies and so there
were things like stealing a bike from a
garage or taking plastic glasses you
know snatching them off a table at a
restaurant or passing a bad check or
selling small amounts of drugs which is
what Bilal was doing to his friend
quote/unquote at the pub so your
sentence was six life sentences plus 150
years yes what exactly did you do so we
have a little pub in my neighborhood a
little neighborhood bar so we all used
to go there drink
play darts and stuff and this guy inside
the bar one day came up to me and a few
of us and said hey do you guys anybody
know how to you know just ask anybody
know where to get any uh any meth or
something I said yeah get him something
so we did this a couple of times had his
phone number called him a couple times
and each time you did this I found out
later he was an undercover cop
Wow so I had prior strikes or anything I
did after that was a mandatory minimum
25 of life what were the previous two
strikes I had years ago okay so there
was a big gap between the first two
strikes and then 16 years three strikes
it to a lot of people that makes
intuitive sense because you're these are
people who have committed two felonies
and they've then committed a third
felony or a misdemeanor that could be
prosecuted as a felony a lot of people
don't even need two chances and we're
giving people three chances explain why
that is a misguided mindset people age
out of criminal behavior I mean the more
research we do on the brain we've
learned that and it's something that's
getting known more in sort of social
science circles the idea of transitional
age youth from 18 to 25 your brain is
not fully developed and most of us have
either been 18 to 25 or know someone who
is knows that a lot of really bad
decisions are made when those decisions
intersect with things like class and
race disparities in the way that
punishments are meted out then you just
have a really bad situation for a huge
swath of young people who then realize
the error of their ways and have grown
up and sort of moved on and are held to
these crimes that they committed early
on we have the highest incarceration
rate in the world here in the United
States but then on the other hand crime
has been going down all violent crimes
and going down so some people might say
well putting all the bad people in jail
is kind of worked the percentage of
three-strikers is very small like a drop
in the bucket of the overall prison
population 650,000 people many of whom
people think of as the bad guys right
because they went in once than the women
twice are coming back out so the numbers
have just grown and grown and grown over
the years not just in terms of who's
going in but in terms of who's coming
out so I think that the causality breaks
down right there from my perspective is
there an alternative to just locking as
many people up as possible for as long
as possible while still reducing the
crime rate absolutely I mean there's
nothing new Under the Sun I really
believe that and there are plenty of
studies really good science like
broad-based studies that show that
alternatives to incarceration like
mental health courts like drug courts
make a positive impact on the crime rate
and on the lives of individuals you can
take it as you know sort of the ethical
mercy moral argument and the lives of
people who have struggled or you can
take the self-interest argument and say
what kind of community do I want to live
in either way you're gonna look at these
studies and say it absolutely doesn't
make sense to give people a felony
record for a drug issue there was an
expert in the film who's talking about
the psychological effects of prison on
people and especially when you have a
life sentence and you start to believe
that you're never going to get out and
you
start to accept that and then suddenly
this change happens and you do get out
that it's hard to get over that
psychological barrier did you have any
experience with that or did you see that
when you were in prison I will out a
doubt saw other people with that I also
while I was there I had made my mind up
and I was pretty clear and pretty
confident that I was never getting out
right but then I had to make a choice I
wanted to be still a better person I
wanted to learn more about me I wanted
and I was angry with me because I'm here
again for the second time or the third
time so I was angry with me and I needed
to forgive me so I had to forgive me by
making myself better I had to find out
what was my reasonings what led me down
those roads that's what just what I did
I also saw people who just had given up
you know a guy who stole a VCR or or
stole his mother's car because he was so
strung out on drugs and he needed to get
to where his gun so she calls the police
and he gets 50 to life for that right
and his mother had had made the call
only because she wanted her son back but
she didn't know this was gonna happen to
him so then he is psychologically ruined
the rest of his life it was in the 1990s
at the federal level it was under the
Clinton administration that a lot of
this tough sentencing was pushed now
there's kind of like a bipartisan push
to undo a lot of these these problems
could you talk a little bit about the
kind of strange politics of prison
sentencing it has been a strange
bedfellows story on California and
national criminal justice I think you
know what we saw in the 90s was a
combination of things but there was
definitely the Willie Horton Michael
Dukakis moment
Dukakis actually didn't pardon him
directly it was a state policy of
furlough where people could go home on
weekends if there were certain goodtime
behavior and he committed a gruesome
crime over the weekend and it was just
splashed all over the media and Dukakis
you know the finger was pointed it to
caucus and so there is I think a terror
on the left or among Democrats of being
that guy right who's weak on anything
and so it was the Democrats were worse
than the Republicans on criminal justice
issues it was like everybody was trying
to outdo each other on tough on crime
for years now wow I mean the fact that
it's the like the one issue that
Democrats and Republicans can agree on
who would have thought back in the 80s
and 90s as mass incarceration was
growing it has been fascinating to watch
kind of incredible and frustrating part
of the documentary is you show
prosecutors who were fighting against
the release of these nonviolent
offenders who've been in prison for
years or even decades for no seeming
reason they these people have never done
anything in prison that indicates that
they would have they would be a threat
on the outside what do you think is
motivating these prosecutors to try to
fight against the release of people I
mean there's a tension within the role
to seek justice and to win and she often
winning is what triumphs in terms of
motivations and prosecutors offices are
built by how many convictions they get
more money more assistant DA's
so there's a real problem of there being
an institutional incentive to not seek
justice but to win and then to hold on
to those convictions in many cases
people don't want and you see this even
in the innocence cases where there's new
DNA evidence people fighting because
they don't want their convictions
overturned they don't want to see the
law change so why not fight these cases
why not fight it why not go on record
and saying I didn't want this guy I
don't want this guy I don't want this
guy as many as possible my understanding
of the law is it's at their discretion
they don't have to fight these releases
right they don't they don't it was
really completely it was it was
completely up to them it was they
decided who they wanted to who they
wanted to contestant who they didn't
when it came up to me mine was contested
my
I have no idea why they're even
contestant but they are so let's go on
with everything we have that's actually
why he decided to do this film he wasn't
really that eager to be a you know to
document his having and three striker
you know for the world to see when he's
trying to get rid of that history but he
was really at risk of not being let out
and he wanted the sunshine in what's the
takeaway that the rest of the country
can learn from what California did here
with prop 36 this historic moment of
allowing thousands of lifers out of
prison it works I mean the recidivism
rate is relatively very low and that
it's something that people should be
willing to take a chance on because the
evidence points and now there's very
recent I think Washington Post published
a study yesterday that said of the
27,500 released under prop 36 and 47 the
evidence is that there it hasn't led to
any increase in crime it certainly led
to huge savings and it's a it's a win
win for the people coming out and the
public near the end of the documentary
you say that the stigma of being an
ex-convict kind of follows you into
every element of the outside world how
do you feel like that's still with you
or have you been able to move past it
and kind of lead a normal life now know
that that's always at this particular
time in life as always with me you know
I'm still looked upon I just want to be
looked upon as the man that I am today
the person that I am I am not the same
person I used to be I've learned a lot
about myself and I am and I don't want
to continue to be looked upon as that
person of the things that I used to do
that I'm ashamed of but I wish I never
had done and I should be upset with
myself but now I am very happy with me
I'm very excited not forgiving me so I'm
not that person anymore but all is a
testament to the power of individual
will and determination to overcome and
succeed but we shouldn't be making it
that hard for people coming out they've
served their time I mean I think we have
to think of it more like people
returning from
or you know with PTSD and attendant
issues and how can we then help them in
a way that also helps us as a society
the documentary is the return it
premieres on PBS
Monday May 23rd Katy Bilal thank you
very much for talking to us thank you
than that thank you
for reason TV I'm Zach why smaller
you